[Applause]
as you can tell from the great speckled
walls behind me I've once again found
myself in an airport but this Airport is
different from most not only because
it's playing smooth jazz but also
because it contains a hank the side of
my face has been bruised by the hat that
I've been wearing it's also a little
warm in this Airport that your head get
too big no my heads are the right size
it's your head that's too big no but
like to do head get bigger and your hat
stops fitting hmm is there a disease
that makes your head bigger berries Hank
thanks for mentioning it hey Hank what's
the embarrassing story that got cut from
the podcast that's your most
embarrassing story ever I don't think
it's that embarrassing but everybody I
tell it to is like no you can never say
that out loud okay then you just tell it
tell it I'm ready it's time you you're
one of the people no the time has come
now actually I've decided I'm doing back
I mean look the second most embarrassing
thing about Hank is that he faked a
British accent for a full year when he
was a teenager what was your favorite
class that you took in college mine was
about the emergence of Islam in Central
Asia which is a little bit niche but it
was a great class I liked all my classes
except for physical chemistry that is
not how I felt about College have either
of you ever considered getting contact
lenses I got contact lenses for a little
while when I was in high school they
dart my eyeballs I just don't like the
way I look without glasses I feel like
I'm not myself yeah no word total space
aliens ready mm-hmm
[Music]
music waking I feel like we should be
slow-dancing would you ever consider
writing a novel together you know I'm
surprised that you said yes now I'm
thinking maybe the answer should be yes
yeah because there would be really great
spaceships and also great love stories
oh god I don't want to write a love
story set on a spaceship can I just have
it be a room but then the room is
happens to be in a spaceship no story
takes place in a room yeah like they're
in space prison or something yeah space
prison love it's what it's called - the
name of the book it's happening based on
my current writing phase look for it in
2031 do
you do you want to see the text message
you sent me where you were like I have a
great idea I did that was a great idea
that was a million dollar idea and I my
feelings are hurt that you're even gonna
read the text messages if it weren't a
million dollar idea a novel that's
comprised of a single fifty two thousand
word YouTube comment that is a great
idea and it's a free idea I'm sending it
out into the world would you want your
collective portmanteau to be jank Orhan
yeah the collective portmanteau thing is
for people who are like in love and
dating and like Bennifer yeah William H
Macy and Felicity Huffman are dating
they've been together for like thirty
years and they're couple name is Fillie
MH month man what would be your Patronus
like a little baby bear tiny little baby
cub lovely a little cute little cobby's
brilli nearly falls over sometimes so
mine would be a very old fox like an
elephant somebody left an inflatable
cran at the checkpoint and that's cause
for a full airport alarm 100% some mom
somewhere was like oh thank god we like
right on pink why does my cat smell like
a diseased goat you should get that
checked out why do you know what a
diseased goat smells like 20 years from
now what would you say to someone who
wasn't alive about what now felt like oh
I don't it felt very you know what it it
felt like starting a lot of sentences
but not knowing how to finish them Hank
it's so fun to be on tour with you and
Katherine thanks to everybody who's been
here thanks to the Madison Airport for
being so accommodating and also for
their really smooth smooth jazz I will
see you on Friday but also now let's go
eat food